brought to the crew now you guys have
some where is he
Colin what the hell's going on give me
some life into war good to show on the
Harriet hey lad Bible I'm Danny DeVito
I'm Colin Farrell and we're gonna be
playing snack walls what's in there
let's open it up holy let me get him
tell me based on appearance that what is
that you lose already what is that
that's Marlon I love a fluff is that
what you guys eat that's what my kids
are where do you stick it that's what I
want to know okay
back of the spoon kam marsh beer is this
um this is Irish via Bolin's are good I
like you know mine and I taste yours
that sounds wrong because I'll go into
like some kind of like shocked if I have
sugar
I brought some rights not one we don't
want this I got the little you got the
vent
okay the EpiPen okay I need it it's very
expensive these days
the drug companies no class orchestral
gluten yeah really
mm-hmm okay well we'll take your word
for it this is probably really great
Irish food okay all right what else you
got Benton a net that intention he knows
what's in there
holy Sh what the hell is this taser oh
you've got to use the branch to a piece
of white bread and some water what do
you put down a real party is this Irish
food again that's American you can tell
them combos below blue cheese bacon we
can't fit in a home in my god wait is
the grace let's open this one up I said
with the Buffalo though he that's it
cooked since night oh man look at that
look at that he's only brought to the
crew now you guys have some all right
everybody grab it both snack wars here
we go good do it like they have to eat
too you know they're over there running
the equipment get out of here go on take
and they gotta clean up
that's the how you doing I'm already
over there are you eating yeah cuz we're
winning we make better stuff you have to
throw your [ __ ] away
they might what is that no thank you
no because I'm telling you I'm throwing
my paper I know yeah come on what that
next let's go what what are you calling
this on newspaper in a sandwich and I've
eaten orange this is be found on every
building site in Ireland Club Arnage
really yeah nice if you have that Oh
what is this beer exampie it's got sugar
in it I can't eat it
okay win here we go let's open it it
goes the next interview I win I can pull
a limb here okay I win
yeah root beer does anyone have this
side of the pond like grow ferrets weird
isn't it
it's like drinking toothpaste this is
real are and does read orange in this
somewhere look with real bits it says
with real bits is a bottle place okay
alright get this out of here all right
tada this o is that Kerrygold what that
cuz I don't know yeah yeah this is my
favorite book that's great yeah I like
it
what the hell is this it's rough it's
American as what of this pink and bright
blue that nasty for you yes this is
fresh lease heart attack wait a minute
when Irish rich barmbrack how would you
get a bit of jewellery in there as well
they should have a ring in that for you
here dude well you know what I mean no
that's what we used to do as kids
there's every way you did it
Yeah right out a little piece okay
smells good
so much for lazy sooo better now you
save enough for later
not for me give it back to me thanks
daddy you're gonna have it okay let's go
how it stirred the cake one for sure
yeah we like the cake ready ah
what are we good Irish owed me a bit oh
man top there ready to eat oh yeah says
you
you want to eat it come over here
already take a bite oh come on yeah not
it ready to eat come on like let's yeah
that that part you gotta clean up later
come on ad-lib fell apart to God look at
popstar do wait you didn't put the glue
in here come over here come on right
there good take a bite
come on guys nice bite out of it okay
alright
somebody call I think I think Ireland
wins with the cookies right taste that
good just bought her Irish all oatmeal
cookies again better than those contacts
good good
I think Ireland wins thanks man I'm
giving it to you yeah I mean it's really
good that was fantastic
shit's should say should sell if you
should sell a few tickets without one
[Laughter]